>> WE'VE SHOWN YOU MANY EXAMPLES
OF VIOLENT CRIME.
YOU WILL REMEMBER THAT.
THE PRESIDENT LOST IN THEM ON
TWITTER AND SAYING DOING SO
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
DO THEIR JOB.
WAS ASSAULTED IN FORT TOMEI
PORTLAND, OREGON.
HE'S NOW SPEAKING OUT.
>> THIS WILL PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR LOCAL AUTHORITIES
AND FEDERAL AUTHORITIES TO START
INVESTIGATING THIS CRIMINAL
CARTEL FOR THE STREET THUGS THAT
THEY ARE.
HAS A POLITICAL IDEOLOGY.
IT'S BEEN FOUR WEEKS SINCE THE
ROBBERY OUTSIDE THE JUSTICE
CENTER.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A SINGLE
ARREST.
>> Dana: TO PROVE THAT I DID
PREPARE FOR THIS SEGMENT, EVEN
THOUGH I WASN'T PREPARED AT THAT
MOMENT, THE QUESTION IS THAT YOU
CAN THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX ON
TERRORISM, BUT NOT OUTSIDE THE
CONSTITUTION.
I'M CURIOUS WHAT YOU THINK, GRE
GREG.
YOU CANNOT HAVE PROTECTIVE
SPEECH IF YOUR SPEECH IS USED TO
HELP CRIMINALS CREATE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE.
>> Greg: THE SIMPLE SOLUTION
IS TO REMOVE THE MASKS.
THEY ARE ONLY WEARING MASKS TO
ESCAPE THE CONSEQUENCES.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BLAME THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: OH.
OKAY.
DO YOU WANT TO BLAME THE MEDIA?
>> Greg: THEY ARE A VERY
VIOLENT GROUP OF LOSERS.
THEY DON'T REPRESENT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY DO FIND SHELTER IN THE
GREATER BELIEF.
THAT WAY, IF YOU BELIEVE YOUR
ADVERSARY IS EVIL AS OPPOSED TO
WRONG, THAT AREA HAS BEEN PUSHED
BY THE MEDIA.
THE WHITE DANDRUFF FALLING FROM
CNN'S HEAD.
YOU COULD HAVE SAVED THE SHOW
SECONDS.
SEE FOR IT GOES TO
SUPREME COURT.
THE SUPREME COURT SAYS IT'S
FINE, WHAT'S TO STOP OTHERS FROM
BEING TARGETED IN THE SAME WAY?
THE ARGUMENT FOR NT FOR BEING A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION.
>> THERE ARE PROBLEMS WITH
CITIZENSHIP.
YOU CAN ALSO DESIGNATE GROUPS
LIKE THIS AS GAMES WHICH GIVES
LAW ENFORCEMENT MORE POWER TO
INTIMIDATE THEM.
ANTIFA DOESN'T REPRESENT ALL
DEMOCRATS, HOWEVER, DEMOCRATS
ARE PROTECTING ANTIFA.
THE PORTLAND MAYOR HAS CLAIMED
THAT HE CONDEMNS IT, BUT HASN'T
MADE AN EFFORT TO ACTUALLY
ARREST PEOPLE.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE ASKED ABOUT
THIS, THEY RUN AWAY AND DON'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION, WHEREAS THE
TEA PARTY IS NOT A VIOLENT
GROUP, THEY WERE ACCUSED OF ALL
OF THESE THINGS AND EVERY
REPUBLICAN WAS ASKED TO CONDEMN
THEM.
>> Dana: THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
DEFINITION OF TERRORISM IS TO
TRY TO ADVANCE YOUR POLITICAL
GOALS THROUGH VIOLENT MEANS.
>> Greg: WHAT WAS THAT?
SORRY.
I'M GOING TO BE DOING THAT FROM
NOW ON.
NO, I KIND OF DISAGREE.
I WOULD SAY I DON'T WANT THEM
LABELED A DOMESTIC TERRORIST
GROUP.
I THINK IT GIVES THE GOVERNMENT
TOO MUCH AUTHORITY OVER AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY'VE NEVER KILLED ANYBODY.
THE BLOODS AND THE CRIPS, I MEAN
THEY'VE DONE MUCH MORE DAMAGE
AND KILLED MANY MORE PEOPLE.
WHITE NATIONALISTS HAVE KILLED
MANY MORE PEOPLE, MUCH MORE
DANGEROUS.
IT LITERALLY IS A BUNCH OF PALE
WHITE KIDS LIVING IN THEIR
PARENTS BASEMENT.
>> Dana: THEY HAVE NOT MADE
ANY ARRESTS.
>> Jesse: THE POLICE HAVE A
VERY HANDS-OFF APPROACH.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT INTERESTING
THAT THESE GUYS DON'T PULL THIS
IN NEW YORK OR BOSTON OR
CHICAGO.
IT'S ONLY IN PORTLAND.
IT'S ONLY LIKE 50 PEOPLE.
>> Dana: LET'S TURN IT OVER TO
YOU ONE.
>> Juan: ANYONE WHO IS
PERPETRATING VIOLENCE, POLITICAL
OR OTHERWISE, THEY SHOULD BE
ARRESTED.
I DON'T KNOW WHY NO ONE'S BEEN
BUT I WILL SAY THAT IN TERMS OF
THIS, ANTIFA MEANS ANTIFASCIST.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROTESTING
AGAINST THE WHITE NATIONALIST,
FASCIST ACTIONS THAT THEY
PROCEED ON THE OTHER SIDE CAN BE
LEGITIMATE PROTESTERS.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE TO BE
VIEWED AS A THREAT TO SOCIETY.
CHRIS, THE FBI DIRECTOR SAID
THAT MORE THAN HALF OF ALL
DOMESTIC TERRORISM IS WHITE
NATIONALIST.
LET'S NOT DOUBT HIM.
I THINK IF THERE SOMEONE YOU
WANT TO DESIGNATE AS A THREAT TO
US.
A GUNMAN WHO WAS APPARENTLY
POSTING WHITE NATIONALIST
MANIFESTO.